how birth order affects our
personalities fascinates many of us and
it's not just at Christmas time when
we're arguing over why the elder sibling
has to peel potatoes and why everyone's
forgotten the middle child has no gravy
with their lunch although you may not
realize that you've probably absorbed
these stereotypes from birth order
Theory birth order theory is the idea
that our position in our family affects
our personality characteristics our IQ
and even our life success and that these
last long into a dull heads now at this
point I should probably let you know
that I am the youngest of four but I
absolutely promise you that that will
not bias in any way whatsoever the
information I'm about to give you now
one of the most influential characters
in this story was Alfred Adler an
Austrian physician and psychotherapist
he wanted to try and understand why
children who were raised in the same
family seem to have different
personalities now at this point I should
mention that Alfred Adler was actually a
middle child the second of seven
children in 1927 Adler theorized the
birth order affected personality hugely
because parents treated children
differently according to a weber eldest
or the youngest he also believed that
parents comparing siblings created a
sense of inferiority since then
researchers have added to this list of
birth order characteristics here are
just some of them they might ring a few
bells for example the older child
thought to be a people pleaser
responsible reliable cautious but
perhaps bossy and controlling the older
child traditionally has been thought to
be given a lot of parental attention so
when the second serving arrives they can
often feel neglected or dethroned
famous older children include Winston
Churchill and JK Rowling the middle
child is thought to be often left out
ignored so they tend to be the
peacemaker they tend to adapt their
personality to fit in with perhaps what
the older child has already taken away
in that family niche famous middle
children include Bill Gates and Madonna
the youngest child is often thought of
as being self-centered manipulative fun
entertaining and charming the youngest
child is often thought to have to work
harder to get attention and to maintain
independence and seem different from
their siblings famous younger children
include Cameron Dean
and Mahatma Gandhi and if you don't have
siblings and don't feel left out because
Adler had something to say about the
personality characteristics of people
without siblings only children are often
thought to be self-centered independent
looking for approval and mature as they
have no older or younger siblings as
they often take on the personality
characteristics of either the eldest
child or the youngest child famous only
children include Daniel Radcliffe and
Leonardo da Vinci in 1996 American
psychologist Frank solloway theorized
that these differences may be due to
Darwin's theory of competition and
survival within every family every child
has to compete for parental attention
and investment in order to survive so
for example the elder sibling taking on
the responsible role of looking after
the younger siblings so when the younger
child comes along they have to develop a
different way of being in that family
and find their own niche for example by
being more adventurous by doing this
they reduce competition and enhance
cooperation within the family so chance
of survival for everyone are increased
over time results of further studies
have been inconsistent so I have totally
backed up Adil Astari others have
totally negated it some studies have
shown that our differences that these
are not meaningful and others have shown
that actually any differences found are
due to study design for example how many
siblings are in a family or the relative
ages of siblings so who knows birth
order is a fascinating subject but
pinning down exactly what impact it has
if any is still a massive challenge but
from a personal perspective I still
think the youngest child is by far
superior thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon